[Aplausos]
pois é a maternidade ea paternidade
embora elas sejam esses sejam eventos
muito diferentes é tem uma certa
similaridade quando a gente começa a
falar sobre isso ea gente cada vez mais
vai sendo colocado em caixinhas e essas
caixinhas vão dizendo um pouco do jeito
de como a gente deveria ser
embora não sejamos muito diferentes bom
a maternidade às mães têm o donato de
cuidar
as mães são mágicas porque elas
transformam o tempo né 24 horas dura
mais
elas são a salvadora as supermães e os
pais são aqueles que expressam medo e
fraqueza
são sempre os protetores os corajosos os
fortes aqueles que não choram são os
mais divertidos chefes de família
só que isso não é bom para ninguém
quando a gente começa colocar as pessoas
ea maternidade ea paternidade em
caixinhas a gente vai rotulando as
pessoas e deixando a perdendo a
oportunidade de ser mais livre quando é
a gente começa a pensar sobre isso sobre
a maternidade
a gente descobre que um mais um é igual
a 3 que a lógica da matemática da vida e
no meu caso foi assim
essa minha família esse é o marco meu
marido esse é o drinque meu filho e
quando a gente se descobriu grávidos
a gente decidiu construir esse processo
juntos e aí nessa jornada de construção
a gente tomou uma decisão muito
importante nesse processo
a gente não quis saber o sexo do nosso
bebê e aí a gente arranja o primeiro
problema porque por quê
cor de roupa eu vou dar o seu filho ou
para sua filha
tanto faz mas e se for menino e eu de
rosa
qual o problema mas e se for menino e eu
deve este do qual o problema mas meninos
lusa o vestido a identidade de gênero do
meu filho da minha filha não vão ser
definidos pela cor de roupa que ele usa
mas isso é um problema é um problema
para as pessoas então antes do meu filho
nascer
ele já tinha um problema e uma questão
de gênero e agentes vocês já pararam pra
pensar que uma simples decisão como essa
como a gente define que cor de roupa a
gente vai dar um bebê pode definir
coisas muito significativas para a nossa
vida e aí veio a nossa segunda decisão
eu consegui tive a oportunidade eo
privilégio de ficar sete meses de
licença maternidade e aí é meu marido
que é muito ser pai e na sociedade que a
gente vive
os cinco dias são suficientes para os
homens entenderem o que eles vão
entender a vida inteira
e aí você fica pensando os homens não
são preparados que o donato de cuidar
das mulheres na gente e aí você fica
pensando o que você pode fazer com cinco
dias
a maioria queria muito ser pai eu falei
puxa que oportunidade bacana e aí juntos
nós tomamos a decisão de sair do
trabalho e ficar um ano de licença
paternidade
legal né lindo
só que não foi assim que as pessoas
entenderam quando a gente toma essa
decisão eu voltei ao trabalho as pessoas
perguntavam assim pra mim bom que está
seu filho agora com meu marido mas ele
tinha ninguém pra deixar ele
então ele está com o meu marido mas
ninguém e não foi uma ou duas ou três
pessoas
muitas pessoas disseram isso e aí é
interessante que a gente não pensa mas a
paternidade ativa só tem benefícios pais
ativos têm maior probabilidade de formar
os filhos de construir processos de
linguagem sociabilidade das crianças de
construir crianças mais seguras mais
simpáticas e menos propensas a ter essa
visão sobre lugares mulheres em lugares
de homens
no final das contas é bom para todo
mundo porque quando os pais podem
construir relações mais saudáveis com a
família
eles ganham muito mais carinho e muito
mais amor
mas se mesmo com tudo isso porque que a
gente com os contínuos vivendo isso
quando a gente toma essa decisão um
marco tinha muitas oportunidades de sair
com modric e aí era muito interessante
que pessoas na rua que a gente nunca
tinha visto na vida se sentiu no direito
de tirar o modric do colo dele porque um
bebê no colo de um homem é perigoso
imagina uma pessoa que eu nunca vi na
vida
fazendo isso ou por exemplo no ônibus
ele contou várias situações dessas nossa
beijando e mostrando o carinho com
modric nossa que linda sua filha não é
meu filho não que seja tanto esse tipo
de coisa vai colocando uma uma limitação
e barreiras onde elas não deveriam
existir porque os 36 associados à
maternidade carinho cuidado e casa não
são associados à paternidade e ao mesmo
tempo os três
fez associados a paterninade que são
provedor protagonista e patrão não são
associados da maternidade e aí a gente
começa a ensinar para as meninas que as
meninas têm sê cuidadoras que as meninas
têm que ser lindas ea gente ensina para
os meninos que eles têm que ser chefe
que eles têm que ser líderes
eles têm que ser fortes e ao mesmo tempo
a gente julga as pessoas pelas outras
escolhas que elas fizeram que foge a
esses padrões
então eu que tinha ficado sete meses de
licença maternidade e agora está
construindo voltando pra minha carreira
profissional
nossa mas se desnatura dá porque você
deixou seu filho sozinho
onde já se viu fazer isso e não só as
pessoas mas como eu muitas vezes era
pega com os meus próprios traídos pelos
meus próprios pensamentos pensando puxa
será que eu fiz as escolhas certas
será que era isso que eu deveria ter
feito será que eu deveria ter construído
um caminho diferente e devia estar mais
tempo com meu filho e ao mesmo tempo
julgando o marco pelas escolhas que ele
tinha feito de ficar em casa então
chegava em casa para mim porque você fez
desse jeito porque é o meu jeito de
fazer aí né
mas por que você não fez tal coisa
a gente reclama que não fez aí tá bom
então como é que eu deveria ter feito
porque está me perguntando como eu
deveria ter feito
ainda assim nunca tá bom porque ao mesmo
tempo nós aprendemos comportamentos
machistas e a gente reproduz muitas
vezes sem perceber isso não é bom para
ninguém não é bom e não é bom porque
isso nos aprisiona ao invés de libertar
isso só começou a acontecer quando a
gente começou a ser muito claro e muito
aberto entre nós e dizer o seguinte eu
não vou ter que escolher não quero
escolher entre ser mãe e ser uma
profissional
e aí eu comecei a criar
estratégias no meu trabalho pra
encontrar formas de estar mais próxima
do meu filho
e aí o que eu decidi fazer nós juntos
porque isso também é uma decisão de
casar alta a gente
a amamentação a vacinação ea alimentação
não são processos individuais são
processos que a gente decide juntos ea
gente decidiu juntos que pelo menos se
modric quisesse eu ia aumentar até dois
anos
como é que você faz treinamento até dois
anos quando você viaja 15 dias do mês
bom então tá bom então ele vai passar a
viajar comigo eo modric por quase dois
anos viajou comigo em todas as minhas
viagens de trabalho
e aí o que é interessante nossa que
bacana né porque isso é levar sua babá e
aí o marco não porque se eu crio
processos onde eu tenho que ampliar o
número de pessoas
isso vai dificultando eu ia sozinha com
modric e aí uma coisa muito interessante
é que eu encontrei muito mais pessoas
ajudando nas cidades onde eu chegava do
que as barreiras que a gente sempre acha
ou fica buscando seu trabalho com o tema
muito pesado eu trabalho e enfrentamento
à violência contra as mulheres
eu trabalho com pessoas que muitas vezes
é instituições onde a violência é
legitimada e eu nunca tive receio de
levar rodrigo nesses espaços
então os espaços com instituições
policiais reuniões com ministros de
estado porque se eu não consigo ter essa
chance de construir relações onde a
criança possa conviver
a gente está fazendo alguma coisa de
muito errado e isso foi muito bacana foi
simples
absolutamente não é bem aceito
normalmente
agora as pessoas me perguntam por que
você decidiu fazer isso por que você
decidiu expor o seu filho uma vez que
ele não tinha a chance de dizer que ele
podia dizer não né por que você fez isso
eu fiz isso porque eu acho acredito
muito que quanto mais você tem chance de
promover transformações
a maior é a sua responsabilidade
eu ocupava e ocupo ainda um cargo de
gerência e isso me dá a chance de
questionar alguns modelos porque eu sei
que de alguma forma você ouvida porque
eu sei que a maior parte das mulheres
não tem chance de fazer isso porque eu
sei que se eu não trouxer essa
possibilidade talvez outras mulheres não
possam criar porque eu acredito que
histórias mudam histórias e quando eu um
conto a minha história eu ajudo a
influenciar outras mães e outros pais a
construírem relações diferentes e é isso
que eu acredito eu acredito que a gente
possa assim construir não é simples mas
é importante e isso não acontece
mudanças institucionais como o caso das
empresas o caso é das organizações elas
não acontecem por uma definição da
instituição quem faz mudanças são as
pessoas e isso é uma coisa importante a
gente pensar e aí um exemplo que eu
trago pra mostrar o poder que isso tenha
o seguinte esse ano o instituto de
pesquisas econômicas aplicadas fez uma
pesquisa sobre empregabilidade de
mulheres e homens e aumento da
incidência de violência doméstica e aí
uma coisa interessante que eles
descobriram que o seguinte quanto mais
as mulheres vão para o mundo do trabalho
maior é a incidência de violência
doméstica
até aí nenhuma novidade
por que por que a gente construiu
modelos onde se os homens são chefes
esse lugar não é das mulheres e se as
mulheres passam a ocupar esse lugar a
nossa sociedade e os homens não estão
preparados para lidar com esse mundo e
aí muitas vezes a forma de lidar com
isso é a forma da violência
agora uma coisa muito interessante é o
seguinte o aumento do desemprego dos
homens
diferente do que as pessoas imaginam
reduz a violência doméstica porque e aí
as hipóteses que essa pesquisa levantou
é de que quando o homem tem a
possibilidade ea necessidade de viver
outros tipos de masculinidades isso é
benéfico para todo mundo
quando o homem não tem o poder do
dinheiro que é o poder que faz com que
ele usa violência sobre as mulheres
ele constrói ao longo do tempo novas
formas de exercer essa masculinidade e
ele sai daquelas caixinhas que dizem
onde os homens têm que estar e onde as
mulheres têm que está e quando isso
acontece
todo mundo ganha agora a grande questão
é a seguinte se isso é bom
se só temos benefícios fazendo isso
porque a gente ainda não conseguiu mudar
a forma como as empresas e como as
organizações estruturam o seu modelo de
trabalho porque quebrar paradigmas e
construir novos modelos é super
importante todo mundo ganha
só que não é fácil é custoso e é custoso
principalmente para as primeiras pessoas
que decidem fazer essas quebra de
paradigma
isso é muito importante e cabe a cada um
e cada uma de nós pensar como a gente
pode fazer isso nas nossas vidas
repensar todos os todos os
comportamentos que a gente reproduz e
muitas vezes reproduzem não se questiona
por que a gente faz as coisas desse
jeito pra que a gente possa construir
novos modelos e uma vez que a gente faça
isso nas nossas vidas
é importante que a gente consiga fazer
isso para os outros e vocês podem dizer
bom como é que a gente começou e
continuou essa jornada eu sigo lutando
pelo fim da violência contra as mulheres
contra a violência visível e invisível
o marco segue com essa experiência e
levando isso para que outros homens
possam se libertar
nesse modelo de masculinidade que
aprisiona ao invés de nos trazer
felicidade eo modric continua nos
ensinando todos os dias
e a gente fica pensando puxa qual é a
coisa mais importante que a gente
precisa ensinar para ele não é que ele
tem que ser forte é que ele tem que ser
sensível carinhoso e vulnerável e porque
vulnerável
as pessoas acham ser vulnerável é ser
fraco e na verdade ser vulnerável é ser
criativo é ser transformador é poder
lidar com aquilo que você tem de mais
facilidade de mais dificuldade
esse é o nosso papel e agora né eu marco
e modric
seguimos a nossa jornada com mais um
novo membro o membro da família e agora
ligada
a gente vai aprender e aprender a
construir esse novo jornada de um outro
jeito
obrigada gente
[Aplausos]
edano